depuis ce week end au moins cent mille
personnes ont été évacuées du donbass
des exilés qui sont réfugiés en russie
notamment dans la ville de rostov sur le
don où se situe justement notre envoyé
spécial de rap des racines
après l'accueil des réfugiés place à
l'aide humanitaire qui s'organise ici en
russie plus de 200 tonnes de matériel de
première nécessité de l'eau potable de
la nourriture mais également du matériel
médical vont être distribués à travers
la russie plus précisément à travers les
régions qui accueillent les réfugiés du
dombass alors nous sommes ici à rostov
sur le don vous pouvez le voir ces
camions s'apprête à partir dans quelques
minutes ils vont prendre la direction
des centres d'accueil provisoires qui
sont installés ici dans cette région 44
centres d'accueil au total des
opérations similaires ont lieu dans les
autres régions de russie qui accueille
également des réfugiés du dombass une
aide humanitaire organisé et collectés
par la jeunesse du parti au pouvoir le
parti russie unie
les camions continuent d'arriver ici ce
n'est pas terminé ils vont encore
arriver pendant quelques jours il y aura
plus de 40 camions de différentes
régions peut être même plus les membres
de la jeune garde travaille ici depuis
quatre jours nous sommes arrivés samedi
c'est un groupe combiné de bénévoles qui
s'est rendu ici des membres de la jeune
garde du sud de la russie de la partie
centrale est également de la jeune garde
locale de rostov au total quelque 150
personnes sont engagés ici nous
exécutons constamment des tâches
différentes au début bien sûr il
s'agissait de décharger de trier l'aide
humanitaire et de l'envoyer dans les
centres d'hébergement temporaire pour un
réfugié plus de 1000 bénévoles sont
chargés de distribuer cette aide
humanitaire vers les centres
d'hébergement provisoire des bénévoles
qui sont accompagnés de médecins de
psychiatres et de psychologues qui
seront chargées les bras chargés avec
des cadeaux mais aussi des jouets pour
les enfants des réfugiés ils sont en
grand nombre un beaucoup d'entre eux ont
dû quitter parfois leurs parents leur
père qui se trouvent de l'autre côté de
la frontière ils sont ici tout seul tout
seul avec avec leur mère alors selon les
dernières informations des services de
sécurité russes plus de cent mille
personnes des habitants des républiques
autoproclamées de donetsk et de
l'ouganda ont traversé la frontière de
la russie